partire così non è semplice però per
tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo nuovo
video io sono un po dj e benvenuti ha
imposto raid che sarebbe a un caso
nottata di single player ovviamente con
tascone apro la mappa è solo questo c'è
stato un omicidio report è stato
sto giocando solo quindi non sono stato
io quando il among us si sono tutti gli
altri mani da solo con con l'impostore
questo è quello che succede teoricamente
devo fare questa parte cioè come star
aprile tasche sporco demonio non so come
si fa ma non importa perché l'evento
dalla mappa le tasche che devo fare
media posto devo andare qua a destra
perfetto spetta alla luce porca vacca
devo fare qua
f.to open open open e non operano perché
devo riattivare l'energia
ma cosa va quanto fatto bene aiuto
perfetto che adesso cercano di aprire un
coso senza l'energia abbia mi sembra
chiaro fisso salve among horror garbage
tutto ok e fino e fino qua fino qua però
fatto bene ragazzi ha fatto benissimo
per essere fatto il trench efron è fatto
veramente bene le trova il troppo uguale
questa svetta blogging tutto in 3d l'ex
co veloce è quanto tempo se qualcuno non
capiva non mi appare meno male perché
sento l'eco vicini attenzione posso
usare banks ovviamente che non sono un
impostore vado
e passato cuori ma non manca gatto loro
fast e rino perfetto ce l'ha fatta la
signora ragazzi mancano quattro tasche
non male per averlo male non male o
madama no no non ci credo tu metri
codici se va bene che è possibile sono
da solo impossibile
macro santa maria maddalena è veramente
non si può fare sanchez e mi sembra un
po eccessivo
mi sembra molto eccessivo cielo quanto
tempo ciò prima che vada a puntare tutto
però accennato metto qui da solo
centrato 19 devo fare un giro enorme non
posso
e vabbè tu vivi qua dentro lui vive nel
corridoio
qui vive lì dai che palle
maronna volta sei brutto si meno male
che è lento come mia nonna c'è veramente
assurdo va bene dovrei avercela fatta
teoricamente dimostrazione dalla stessa
che è molto difficile star o perché
comunque il fatto che io sia da solo a
fare le tasche d'emergenza cugat ma si
svecchia dalle comunicazioni
però a parte che tutto qua quindi adesso
rifare stretta skin cass
dimmi che non è quello che palle questa
che palle è molto più veloce parla così
di però perché effettivamente era un po
modificata perché quella normale rampa
alla estrema veramente forse l'hanno
modificato apposta essendo anche loro
giocatori chiamo il gas diverte power
nel senso che power quando gioca si
diverte lo sapevo questo ci siamo
cosa che devo fare qua anche questo
madonna che palle siamo due ora fare sta
roba dai guardaci sismologico sopra lo
ispezionata demos pure mi devo staccare
tornare dopo anno che questa cosa
sbagliata c'è veramente due ore di tusk
cimica neanche ora mi liberò monga se
così caffetteria
adesso se corrono con un puledro ce la
faccio a fare l'ultima perché mi
raggiunga teoricamente a noi che non
cambi la velocità non sono così sicuro
di quello che ho detto
victory next level flickr o muoio raga
fix wiring upload ai tablet con power
allora non male però deve solo marconi
ea step a livelli e poi ci saranno anche
più impostori credo che lo so rovello
però per ora è carino continua a far le
tasche finché riesci si chiama stato
praticamente l'unica vera nota positiva
è che cambia la musica quando arriva al
mostro qui lo sento da un gas non lo
sentivo andare infatti dovrebbero
mettere sta cosa che togliere la musica
e soprattutto portamelo celo celo celo
veloce è quanto tempo ciao
io so much mecca sembra sciocca sotto
acidi non ho visto incastrato allora le
ultime due taschine proprio is easy
peasy principi di una sega di penn
ok molto facile
manca una e ho fatto questo è stata
molto più veloce di quella di prima
grande chi stato 66 volte la giocata ma
un cazzo sei anni e non mi ricordo che
si fa le cose bene livello a napoli
comunque con miei ragazzi per assistere
tasky vicine qui non non lontane perché
sennò queste due ore a cambiare posto
prima o poi usciranno due o tre
impostori tutti insieme io me lo sento
so che è così sto gioco lo sento proprio
finalmente data lamon gas che almeno
tutte ste robe le sua memoria almeno
quello adesso la luce porca [ __ ]
forse lo triplo forse privato
non sa neanche accorto che lo 4 con una
raccolta del porca [ __ ] veloce zio
veloce casterino masterino forza che mai
ok ok campo ce l'ho fatta manca role
lights light yagami come non sta proprio
qua vedere c'è qualcuno che ha
scoraggiato ho sentito proprio perche
slide ko one free mancano solo due tasti
che stanno lì esattamente lì
let's go di mykonos ha i conti in rosso
quasi ne consegue non sai quando stai
quando sei con secco alle uome brothers
vai con la carta ok poterlo fare qua
madonna ragazzi che gioca a torino
proprio lui proprio lui la finisce
sempre la porta veloce per i knights
very nice e livello 4 ok sta diventando
benifici adesso sono tutte distanziate
le cose ottimo cioè ottimo una sega
faccio un giro largo così le faccio
tutti i giorni nera che l'unico modo per
far sì che di ottimizzare il tempo
insomma farle tutte in ordine sarà un
casino questo anche in a con gara serata
prova madonna che quello ha squartato
vicino al joubouri ha esportato in un
video che riprende i capelli st blogging
mi ricordo quando avevo windows xp nel
2000 e zero molto divertente ragazzi che
mettevi il cursore sulla blog dove stava
andando avanti o se prevista di tutta la
vita ok va bene fa che non vada giù le
luci ti prego no kat
per a lipari find my friends mani
vai veloce zio
le porte tutte orco demonio madonna
pensavo fosse qua ero convinto fosse
quali sono cagato nelle mutande
le manca ora qualcuno che scoreggia
sempre quando non me l'aspetto attentato
fare tutto il giro l'elenco sarà
fotografato no fly slice no dai ti prego
fix l'ice adesso lorca trottola fatto
tutto manca solo quello di sliven ei ok
ok va a manas l'ex cloro ma tu fai
veloce mio dio siamo livello 5 ragazza
normale non male non me la sto cavando
per lui onesto very nice level file con
divani ci sono in totale qui ed ora
serve per un'amica ti puoi nascondere
sotto i tavoli stanza mi fa impazzire
era che non so perché allora lato destro
prima soprattutto adesso che non sono si
sono picchiate le luci perfetto allora
vai questa la faccio veloce questa mi
sembra però molto più fattibile
poi la volta che perdo ma vabbè quanto
tempo per finire che nella lega non
entrato le scopo
per ora niente male eh
mi sa che sta entrando non vorrà di
sbagliare salve arriva arrivederci
amiche i codici va bene
o no
madonna ganz madonna ma sto giocando
molto bene comunque non è così difficile
per me per adesso poi non lo so che
altre frustrante forse che cazzo sceglie
un cappello da festa va bene
spero di non peccare l'altro quello che
stavo per dire meglio peccato cavaliere
sono lenti come la morte perché sono
ascoli 28 bene è veloce mi fido mi fido
non so se faccio bene ma mi fido
ma no che giocata padona come mi sono
pagato per un nulla cosmico per un nulla
cosmico che culo
minchia raga tanto così mi sono fidato
ma ho fatto malissimo perché avendo
rischiato la morte ma fa niente
madonna che culo estremo salve
è lottizzato denuncia meta è la madonna
raga
sono stato una maniera più assurda del
mondo
ok cifre ei
la madonna minchia aspettavo aspettando
ho provato un dribbling ho detto vabbè
lasciamo perdere oggi non sono cristiano
ronaldo
faccio il tifo da che mi frega a me
dovrebbe fregare dai almeno c'è la
nostra da clean
sono un po sporco di rosso nell'anima ma
non capisco perché sarà per compreso
danno non ho preso la si prendono fuori
direttamente
che strano che sia un pelino rosso e
vado
ok
ok dai dai che l'ultimo merda
ma.mo nostro livello 9 ott io benedetto
è un bordello qua sono tutti sparsi
nella maniera più assurda allora
conviene fare tutti mica quella
veramente difficile ragazzi aspetta
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
vado passo di qua melo perché ero
sicuramente nel corridoio centrale ma ci
provo
quando io le cose le so e perché le so a
favore gira al contrario facciamo prima
i corpi vogliono il cesso sempre
spostati in posizioni rea se questa con
ai minimi tring era veloce zio che
questi sono più veloci di prima veloce è
merda madonna
raga aiuto alle strettissime
ho saputo poi cosa hai fatto merda ma
preso porca vacca mc stava laicità
uscita ballo pubblico è stato bello è
stato bellissimo
finché non sono morto nel senso poi no
se lo potevo fatto la vela non fatte 9
di dai fenomeni siano 100 ragazzi fatevi
selezionate episodio quasi ad essi viene
più giornata è andato e basta ring
cervello stavo facendo il coso della
descrizione prima di dire dalla
schizzata devo prendermi una pausa una
camomilla soprattutto bella ragazza è
bella ragazzi
[Musica]